[Music]  another epic installment of carpool  karaoke on The Late Late Show with James  Corden this time with the Jonas Brothers  who recently reunited after six years  apart when I got them back together it's  true there's a story guys and James  rocked out to some of their greatest  hits opened up about the band's initial  breakup and how they went through some  much-needed healing while filming their  documentary  when things ended it wasn't the best  forced therapy yeah camera and then in  that we started saying you know there  was a magic when we were together that  we would all love to feel again James  jokes that the Joe Broz may need to get  all of their drama out in the open as he  brings a lie detector into the mix and  Nick hilariously got candid about his  multiple weddings to wife Priyanka  Chopra was there a point during your  many weddings that you thought I'm done  with these weddings yes  it was when I looked at the bill  [Music]